Shane Dawson but you know when that kid
at school is going around telling
everyone that that kids gave that kids
game that kids game when you really you
find out a few years there that was the
kid who wanted everyone else to be gay
right it's Shane Dawson that with
sociopaths
yeah we're setting the question we're
gonna try and answer that in this
podcast you're a sociopath
yeah and so [__] maybe all this
empathy we've seen from Shane Dawson is
him exploiting people for views on his
channel and he's the real sociopath
that's sociopathic shame keeps looking
at the camera cord like doing you made a
compilation justif Shane's likes to the
camera
I must admit he does he makes me laugh
is that's the thing when you're not
aware you can't then I don't know I
can't then play dumb yeah let's do the
pod ready ready sorry that's not a
sponsorship so we're not but true Jodi
podcast episode is a 1 or 3 I think one
he's 103 yeah we promised each other
we'd do 100 together but then yeah I'm
sorry about that yes alright things got
in the way well I was still using the
camera in a way pod cut podcast what
I've got actually so I've written some
things down because to be honest it's
been a big week in the world of
YouTube's been a big month has been a
long time since you and I just sat down
alone Shane Dawson soft over YouTube
this documentary maker I've seen you're
the real document mimic or a nutrient
documentary we all know that the real
[__] I wanted to talk about you
see you've seen some of it I've seen
episode 1 episode 2 came out last night
but I was I see you never saw 2 was well
by the way I've seen both up tell me
little bit about it because you and I
had our thoughts when we saw the trailer
yeah we saw how much he hyped it up I
respect the grinder and I actually the
only reason I'm bringing this
because it's content worth talking about
so first things I want to give him
credit for that it's not like 99% of
YouTube content which is formed in he's
put effort into this yeah so not an
iPhone review but it's good he's done
he's done a he's got a little nice
little formula of like drama mixed with
hype yeah mixed with storytelling mixed
with good editing I'm revealing emotion
yeah and you package all that together
and by YouTube's standards it's it's
level it's a level up it's you know but
there are things from a person who's
made a documentary before which we both
have you see in that and now everyone
can criticize everyone so I'm not trying
to be a [__] here but like there were
points where I was I because the amount
of hype behind this series cause Shane's
got such a big audience has been
enormous now I'm obviously like not his
core audience anywhere that the
documentaries he's made before this were
about YouTube as that I wouldn't have
one of the one last called Donna
something or other Geoffrey star
deflation guy who rightly a most for
women I'm not I don't mean to be
emotional documentaries where people
broke down and I didn't really watch
them because obviously a kind of no Jake
at this point so I mean he was on our
[__] podcast but I didn't really go
in with Jake because it was sort of a an
unplanned podcaster I didn't really have
time to do me research and it was all
about the fight but yeah first episode I
was just a bit like I wasn't expecting
this folk from all the hype I was
expecting him to come with a lot more I
don't know about you I guess I was just
the the trailer really builds it up and
doesn't it to the point where you you
think wow this is gonna be there's gonna
be something really sensational that's
gonna happen during episode one yeah
he's hyping it I think almost too much
and I understand the game that this guy
wants views he wants his effort to be
seen by a lot of people but you can hype
it up to a point where when you
eventually get to the point it's
building to people are going to be left
unfulfilled
I Jonathan I so for me it felt a little
bit like watching something like the
staircase where Jake Paul is basically
accused of being a sociopath being
associate without actually murdering
anyone later the circus had it beat for
that reason there was a real murder in
life yeah whereas this is just painting
a guy out to be someone who could
actually murder someone basically is
that Oh for me to set the to be fair
he's done a good thing and setting out a
question to be uncertainty straight away
is Jake Paul a sociopath but for me like
I'm just sucks at this straight away
everyone like well where did this come
from what why why is this to question
you and I feel like he's sat down and
thought how do we make this a thing
exactly exactly how do we make a
documentary worth doing about Jake Paul
because hey I want the views from
working with Jake Paul it's gonna blow
my career up massively and [__]
like me are going to talk about it but
really I need a reason to justify to my
own audience why I would [__] with Jake
Paul while still maintaining the
credibility level of of being oh well
I'm here a judge Jake Paul I'm not
actually lowering myself down his where
as in the reality of the matter is is
whether you like it or not if you're a
fan of Shane Dawson these two
[__] are working together to
help each other
and that is the truth yeah I mean we I
also think when you watch a documentary
or when you watch anything you should
almost be able to lose yourself in it
and almost not be aware of the process
yeah and this documentary to me feels
very aware of the process of making a
documentary it feels a little bit like
they went right we're gonna make a
six-part series or an eight part series
and then we're gonna fit the content
back and whatever we get we're gonna
make it fit over this many episodes
right definitely because that first
episode once again I rate the guy higher
than most youtubers this isn't me see
your knees are bad youtuber you're not
so critically implica peace
most of it was just clips from Jay
Paul's channel if most people will know
that the guy's wild he does much [__]
we've seen it all before
and unfair enough paint a picture I
don't dispute using a few minutes of
that but me a full episode 40 [__] how
he stretched out of 45 minutes I don't
know I couldn't believe it at the end
yeah it was like is this necessary
it was also partly that I think we are
coming at it from an angle of what we
would do if we wanted to make it I would
have condensed that right down yeah well
at the point the guy's a nutcase
and he's self-absorbed all right get to
the point there was a lot of does it
does it need 2530 minutes of that
generally a lot of use of the word
sociopath throughout the episode two
people who didn't even I probably
couldn't tell you if someone was a
sociopath because I've not studied
psychology I mean I'm not in that field
another yeah does no sorcery ecology
don't you know in my limited experience
I'd say that Jake Paul is a sociopath so
that limited experience being you've
watched his videos yeah have you ever
met the guy not in person
yeah jr. I mean it was one of those
where everything had to be caveated a
little bit because we didn't quite know
where things were going there are
moments where I think so one of the
things that got me of it because I
watched estroux not being the fun
so I feel like I can as a creator myself
I can't digest this in a different way
if you love Shane Dawson you're going to
enjoy him having a mini panic attack
over the fact that Jay Paul's left him
an answer machine message right for me
I'm like just listen to the [__]
message mate it's just a nun literally
he's a bloke and I listen to the message
that's why I think I think what is the
big wheel I'm shaking I'm like well I
mean you're an overreactor me like if
we're gonna diagnose things out here you
know what would start with you is that
canal son is it also know that we've
slightly normalized Jay Paul's behavior
so it's actually quite a reasonable
thing to be worried about being so close
and trying to do a hit piece on someone
I think that he
so I I'm like I said I'm not familiar
with all this work but I did watch him
on the no jump a podcast yeah where
fouseytube keemstar on there and one
thing that came across to me
similarly yourself at times as he would
give these looks to the camera which
shows how away socially Shane Dawson is
and how he was communicating with the
audience like yeah we all know that this
is [__] it's crazy and he made me
laugh a lot I thought this guy's so
funny and from him to be so aware to
then go out to be the opposite where
he's overreacting himself and I'm like
well you're either really socially aware
and not fazed by the fact that
fouseytube a literal crackpot no offense
but he's having a meltdown next to you
and then all of a sudden that doesn't
faze you you can look at a camera and
make the funny jokey eyes but then
always in an answer machine message
you're shaken that is an inconsistency
do you think that that's part of the
problem is when you're looking at the
role of Shane Dawson he is the emotional
guy he's the guy who can connect with
people there is then a bit of a
disconnect when you see someone for me I
look at first you've and I see a tragedy
I don't see something to laugh at I
don't see someone that I think this is
funny I see someone who's struggling
with life so much and there's a load of
people around we're going toughen up a
little bit and you know be be more of a
man why are you acting this way you
deserve this basically holding like some
sort of a kangaroo court where they
basically go you're guilty of lying
trying to minute late these things and
then people judge him and I find it
weird that Shane Dawson then picks that
role when fouseytube is involved but the
other way when Jake Paul's involved it's
a little bit weird because he knows the
role he knows the role he's playing at
each time to me and to me that seems a
little bit I don't know him
it that doesn't seem it doesn't lie
enough because a bit disingenuous saying
that you know the action yeah cuz to me
fouseytube is in need of a lot more help
than Jay Paul is although Jake Paul may
also be someone who does normos if we're
gonna die ignores anyone I think
fouseytube is the one who
probably needs more psychologists coming
to his house yeah than Jake Paul does
you know them soon one question I think
was quite interesting the erasing
documentary is are we all in this
industry
sociopathic to some extent because we
sit down and it's performance so the
second episode that you didn't see was
him once there's a lot left in there
like him going to a psychologist how
some like this could be in the first
episode yeah you know get to the
psychologists house in the first episode
and construct your argument of what is a
sociopath to start off with yeah like
that could have all been in the first
that's the thing when it's being so
hyped up once again I do feel a bit of a
letdown because standards on YouTube are
law so it takes very little to impress
people right but I did enjoy the fact
that they were setting out a stall of
right this is a sociopath once again it
lasted like [__] 40 minutes when they
could have been done in probably 10 but
you can't help but think when you listen
to a source the description of a
sociopath like yeah everyone has
tendencies of of this sort of I know
people who are good human beings who lie
I know people are good humans who
manipulate at times we've all got that
ability partly to do shitty things to
each other
it doesn't me so what if it reminds me
of Peep Show where you know that they're
trying to get each other sectioned and
then you guys I should have used section
for trying to have me section I'm like
at this point like it's getting a bit
like on Twitter everyone's pointing the
finger you're a sociopath yeah and this
is a word that's being bandied about
willy-nilly it is though and there are a
lot of words that's part the problem is
that we are we are very quick to use
very serious terms so if if someone's
suspected of speaking to a young person
instantly the phrase pedophile is
branded around I'm there are they're
just beautiful and well there are horror
in this culture which everyone wants to
pin a name on each other
yeah when in reality Jay Paul probably
isn't a sociopath he's probably more
likely to be a self-absorbed prick who
got famous very young Rand had I'm gray
reinforced by 17 million P
all [__] on his videos over and over
again I thought you know it's a great
yeah
and it's gone too far and at some point
like with Logan I feel like there's a
there he's having a reality check
oh there's one coming at some point but
that doesn't mean you can sit there and
go sociopath and one of the other
problems I had is in the edit
it's a [__] well edited video or
theirs when they when they're naming the
parts of behavior that line up with
sociopathic tendencies you've got people
like Chris Brown just thrown in there an
interview they hated is Chris Brown a
sociopath because if I'm Chris Brown and
I watch that going I'm [__] so a new
me because you've literally just made me
look like a [__] crazy person yeah
and like and other people in there who
maybe haven't done even as bad a things
as Chris Brown has done and it's like
you can't just meet people look like
they're a sociopath sociopaths
sociopaths it's getting banded about
every time like there is coming this is
crazy to be pointing the finger at so
many people there is also so you spent I
did see one in twenty five you saw maybe
I'm wrong is wrong or maybe you're one
of the twenty five maybe I'm one of them
yeah I mean to figure out sitting on
YouTube with a huge coke sponsorship
talking about him from Columbia thank
you very much
when do we through first started nothing
but the best when Louie through first
started out when Big Brother first
started out when any of these things
first started out people were much less
aware of the effects of them so they're
gone Big Brother and people just act
normally like they're that they think
they're acting normally and they
wouldn't be aware of the whole process
now people go on love island which is
the new Big Brother aware of everything
that will happen they'll they'll be
manipulated there'll be challenges
there's all this kind of thing but but
the thing is even now and this is the
thing that I'm worried that YouTube will
get new is recently a woman who went on
love Island committed suicide yeah and
she said I didn't get the aftercare I
didn't get the like reintroduction into
the real world I was just left to rot
there's something impressionable which
is called duty of care and so on things
like X Factor on things like Britain's
Got Talent
even on Big Brother and things like that
you have a duty of care to the people
who are on it because you're gay
action company you're gaining a lot from
using the personality and using the
person 100% so you have a duty of care
there were questions at times as to
where the fan channels had the same
responsibility for those who don't know
if you're an American fan channels away
football fans run after a game but then
somehow become overnight celebrities as
well and they get their 15 minutes as
that artist said flames they drug it up
with a longer no yeah the whole point is
15 minutes is the arbitrary amount of
time he put on a flash in the pan so
there was questions over whether that
was the case as well the same sort of
goes for the YouTube guys and the famous
people now what I'm saying is now we're
aware of the process we're much more
aware of it documentary making becomes
different because people watching
documentaries are now so aware of the
process of making a documentary that
they will begin to insect it in a way
they'll begin to analyze think about
it's a little bit like when you know the
current lab or a key remote yeah be
people became aware of all right I've
got a watch out for this sort of [__]
yeah so I mean it's a bit annoying for
me because I actually kind of I like the
format for the record I do like the idea
of living with a youtuber and I actually
came to you with the same idea before
when we first started EXO we were
talking about doing you know living with
are doing youtubers but now some
youtubers may be just general sociopaths
we weren't talking just about youtubers
and the Louis Theroux is obviously the
Godfather of that weird weekend style
and I don't
I admire shame for going into this but
yeah I think when I'm watching it
there's so many red flags like at one
point he's having a conversation with
the sociopath expert the psychologist
and he's like yeah I noticed the use sad
music when they want to convey a sad
emotion does that mean and they might
not even know that it's sad all the
while they're having a chart using
sadness on a couch yeah
just the chocolate menu with what can
only be described as horror like saw
music yeah to try and make this sound
like we're in the mind of Jay Paul it's
a crazy spooky place yeah I'm
you're [__] doing it right now yeah
you are doing the same thing that you're
pointing out that Jay Paul does so who's
a real self seal if you are doing so
that's kind of that's the conclusion
we're getting to first rule I think you
should have a chat with Emma Kenny about
what a sociopath is where your own
purposes and define some of these things
yeah
secondly if what is the end goal for you
of a documentary telling a story right
but the problem is is sometimes profit
overcomes integrity and I think with
this with this documentary series I'm
already saying that weighing all over
the shots so is integrity something
which has been degraded over time and
media or do you think integrity never
existed and just let me finish this do
you think integrity never existed and
because we were so new to television
radio constructing things that weren't
just to play or something live we were
naive enough to think that there was
integrity in TV and we were fooled into
thinking that documentary is made in the
50s and the 60s by white guys who all
had degrees and moral qualified were
more had more integrity than someone
does now or are we just aware of the
lack of integrity for a lot of people
that's a very complex question and
that's why I'm asking you because you're
smart enough to break it down we're in
an industry right now what me and you
we've come from different backgrounds
you you come from a documentary making
background I come from offshore [__]
deep-sea right I'm finding that a lot
less people give a [__] about what they
make then I first thought to put it just
narrow it down really quickly I think
she has got integrity but I think he's
willing to compromise in order to also
make something that's gonna catapult his
career and I would do the same thing to
a degree but there has to be a a lion
and when Jake Paul makes a video before
it says watch this before you watch the
Shane Dawson and he says Shane talked to
me and said I'm gonna go down the serial
killer row and I'm gonna make it seem
like you're this guy but you know and
for tragic Paul and let the cat out of
the bag that it's an agreement between
these two guys that that's what they
were going to do entirely and not
eventually because of the nature of
shame from his own admission in the
first two episodes he likes to have a
happy ending so there's got to be a star
drama
issues happy ending I already know where
he's going with this pretty much and I
might be wrong but the fact that they're
like he's even mean he wants a happy
ending which is I appreciate him being
so honest but the fact that she and you
have made that many times but then yeah
especially they were my masseuse look
the thing is Jake Paul is let the cat
out of the bag that this isn't when
you're saying being honest being you
know having integrity there's there's
compromises already being made and so
far I'm just feeling like it's
lightweight it's a bit fluffy it's
[__] at one point there was an old
lady throwing a cat into the bin as it
as a clip of a sociopath I'm like does
that really need a beer yeah like what's
that what's the has G Paul done that no
is that irrelevant to any of this no I
do feel that way in episode one there's
a clip of a plane crash
what's that exactly that made me feel a
little bit
I get it I mean you know in in the exo
trailer we use a lion there's jumping on
another lions to express a bear fighting
over there to express something that's
but that's a trailer for something which
is playful this is Sarah this is
portraying itself yeah has a serious way
of evaluating a person's mental state
and maybe they have a duty of care
towards Jake although maybe everyone
including mean that is naive enough to
then go well he's not I don't think
Jake's conscious as a person in this
maybe Jake's like you saying fully
conscious of where this is going and why
he caveat I get the force of watching
certain well my question but the final
conclusion for me was and one thing that
we sort of evaluated when I was making
documentaries on my courses what is the
final goal of your documentary what are
you trying to make hit me but I would
try and tell a story I think we spoke a
will about this
he says that we're looking at it from a
documentary makers point of view where
we're wanting air the truth you know not
overly dramatized just tell the real
story and what we'll sing is that this
isn't a documentary as much as its there
for entertainment purposes and it's just
called a documentary and shot in the
style of a documentary to make it he
didn't say this but I think maybe it's
me to make it more believable so that
you feel more invested and then when the
entertainment grabs you and the drama
grabs you you don't care that it's a bit
[__] now you're enjoying it
nonetheless it's the suspension of
disbelief yeah is it sport reality part
fake and and that's the fun in it that's
what it takes
it's so in many ways you're sort of
comparing it to like a a Batman so for
example Jersey Shore I love Ireland a
lot of this sort of [__] is semi
scripted or or if it's not scripted it's
edited a certain way to make it far more
entertaining than the actual event was
like for example having a half an hour
chat with the psychologist when in
reality that's quite a nice little
relaxing chat maybe a good podcast but
when you hire all the editing around it
all of the dark music around it make you
feel like we're sitting in Jake Paul's
brain well you know that's not an
accurate depiction of what was going on
but but the fact that they're hyping it
and it's making it more fun
I guess it's where does it stop it's the
fact that you as a viewer are aware of
that and you go on that journey with him
knowing that he's pretending to be in a
brain or wherever he is that sort of
achieves his end goal is that actually
he did say I think in Episode one
something along the lines of I just want
to start that conversation I want people
to think do I want to give this person
view do I want to buy this person's
merch do I want that
and if his end goal is start a
conversation which was is Jake Paul a
good guy not to for his documentary to
make the conclusion but to start people
questioning that then he's found an
entertaining way of raising that
question and that I respect is a big
achieving fair player because I think
too many people watch youtubers for what
they get out of the
and don't think about what the youtuber
themselves are getting out of that
relationship so maybe think when you
click on someone's videos you're doing
them a big favor and maybe treat that a
bit more as do I really want to help
this person and not do I want to feed
into the trick that a lot of these
people use which is clickbait so that is
where an understand we've all done this
is you know YouTube guys everyone
everyone may get to a milestone thanks
the people who support them and people
are right to do that
but it does construct the idea around it
of the sense of community and the sense
of you know I'm with all you guys
sometimes in a community that's that big
boo you suck over 17 million people is a
diverse set of people I love all you
guys yeah and all you're doing that's it
dude no there is when you begin to
question like the structure of YouTube
now and the structure of even because
the funny thing is Jake Paul has
probably got more followers than a lot
of other platforms have got in the first
place like there's more people probably
that you know use and interact with Jake
Paul on a daily basis and go new
SoundCloud or whatever it's different to
the way that previous communities like
television all those sort of things were
constructed I think we're in unknown
waters here and I don't think I said
this in that video you know the exo
video where I'm talking about how media
evaluates YouTube I don't think we will
like the effects of way where YouTube is
going and I think we're blindly walking
into an alley of not great content and
tricking ourselves into thinking that
we're going down the right way because
we're all making money from yeah I think
the need for drama to entertain people
it addressed I find my I was thinking
about this the other day I was driving
along and I was listening to Eminem and
MGK song like just sort of only because
I was trying to think which one do I
actually prefer even though even though
Eminem's is higher level I just kind of
I really like MGK song right anyway I
was thinking about the need for drama
and why why am I so entertained by the
fact that these two guys are talking
[__] about
each other when they're not going to
have a fight nothing's ever going to
come out saying why is this so
entertaining and it's the same thing
that we say on YouTube time and time
again it's the same reason why when
Shane is on the no jumper podcast and
he's given the sly looks the camera and
being funny because he's so aware of
what's going on in the situation and
playing it down and acting like
fouseytube is overreacting by the big
meltdown he's having and then on his own
video he's going I'm sure I made a note
of this actually so I remember being
like I was like watching this site it's
not real is this real life he said he
said that this documentary with Jake
Paul was the breaking moment of his life
the breaking point of his life and I
mean like god I I'm at the point now
where you've hyped this up and built
this up so much that I I'm almost like
this is ridiculous expecting babies to
know I'm like you you you should have
more on the content we haven't even
you're two episodes in you've not even
walked in the guy's house yet where's
the content give me the real [__] and
less of the hype and the drama and the
[__] yes everything we've seen in
two episodes I could have just got you
that in five minutes German there's am I
know I'm bringing up a lot of stuff to
do with degrees whatever my degree that
was a way of evaluating for the record
you have a degree in this [__] but just
in case anyone who has just stumbled on
this so no you know qualified got a
first
the as a betting game so it's the not me
I'm just a tough couldn't know that we
hang out so much you sort of osmosis
yeah I can deep-sea dive you got
immediate agree most people call both
those things [__] useless in daily
larger who do they are yeah fully the so
there's a there are some interesting
ways of evaluating these sorts of people
and interesting ways of evaluating
people like Jake and chaining the Mo's
guys one thing that it does ask and a
big question you should always ask is
what are we borrowing from the past that
we're just bringing up again and we are
almost recycling reusing reinventing
and I got a mint I watch a lot of
YouTube right now and I see almost
Shakespearean tragedy a Shakespearean
drama you can map some of these
characters that are on the trick on a
play and directed and turned up to look
at what happened but there's elements of
that like imagine if Drake had learned
doctors plan alright good so is this a
microphone I see before me so it was to
be fair there is William loves people my
favorite show so there's people like and
this is a compliment to keemstar people
like keemstar are like the puck that's
women Midsummer's Night Dream who sort
of this playful character who will sort
of sit on the periphery and introduce
some form of drama introduce a
challenging question introduce something
which undermines the powerful and it
will just slightly throw them off kilter
and maybe show another aspect of their
character mm-hmm similar to Shane
similar to a Jake or a Logan who's like
you know maybe one of the main
characters in the Midsummer Night's
Dream there's quite a few characters
that have psychotic episodes in
Shakespeare if you look at things like
Twelfth Night and things like that I
don't really remember much I was I was
pretty bad in school but the point is
there are there's a lot of tragedy and a
lot of the same hammer yes well it's all
a drama and they say but no one's gonna
no one wants to watch tragedy you to
know that they want so charming I think
people have quickly realized that you
know we went from the original YouTube
which was pets doing tricks and then
vlogging your shopping halls and then
you know FIFA and whatever and all of
these little waves but eventually people
have realized just like they did with
rap music the most entertaining thing is
to watch people freak out call each
other names just have a [__] fit and
and so there's I just encouraging people
to go even if you don't know about
Shakespeare you don't give a [__] about
Shakespeare and I don't know why you
wouldn't if you understand the way that
people are making tragedy now look at
the plot of Twelfth Night and look at
the plot
go to a late summer night stream I'm not
gonna okay Logan Paul you've told us
enough min Logan Paul and Jake Paul
compared to so many of those characters
and those things proud men who have
built up a lot and have a lot to lose
and find different ways around
humiliation around loss around all these
things and struggle with those ideas and
there are many people who look in
throughout that play and play with them
and we'll you know we're going to back
to the horse sociopath thing yeah you
can be a sociopath yeah fair enough like
I'm not saying that that's not possible
but equally you can also be a less
emotional person and still be perfectly
normal and perfectly fine
yeah yeah I'm not I don't know where
these guys sit on the spectrum I've
spent time with Logan for the record I
don't think he's a [__] sociopath I
think he I think he's very careful do
you know how mean you would be I don't
think he's a sociopath I think he's a
he's not an overly emotional guy at all
he's he's on the law side when it comes
to that but I do not think he's a
sociopath no he's a bit mad though I
must admit but he has a mad life he's
constructed this crazy life and imagine
all those people relying on you on a
daily basis for a paycheck or for a job
you were worried that if I stop this
what happens I just think that these
guys this is my evaluation of to these
two lads after meeting them because I
try and put myself in their shoes like
when if I was in my early like early 20s
and I'd acted like an [__] and got a
very rich life out of that and everyone
kept reinforcing that the comments the
likes and all of a sudden I'm chasing
I'm like I could be though I could be
the biggest guy ever yeah you know me
and and and all of a sudden you've got a
team of people around you licking the
arse all offer you going like you're
going to be the first YouTube
billionaire and you know and and before
you know it you're just trying to find
ways of making the most ridiculous and
crazy videos ever I'm like I thought
about that oh really then I thought yeah
I could have gone down that road I could
have easily happened to me like the
could have so people like an [__]
enough I guess
yes it's true profanity I don't have
that I mean I've spent a lot of time
with a woman but anyway that's another
story the point is I could understand
I'm not saying I'm like either of those
two guys I'm different but I just
understand the road that the vended of
going down in I think putting that label
yeah like I said earlier it's just
dangerous because now all these kids are
gonna be going to school when [__]
Scioscia yes and like maybe someone's
just not so if someone tells a lie
they're instantly a sociopath because
they were trying to manipulate yeah I I
feel like we she's that should have come
towards the end of the documentary that
word shouldn't even be mentioned he
should have had the psychologist on hand
and said I want you to give me an
evaluation of what you think of this guy
over the course of this time and if at
the end of the eighth episode she goes
well I've thought about everything I
have to say the conclusion is probably a
sociopath that would have made sense but
for him as a man who isn't educated in
that field to my knowledge to just drop
that in at the start several times I
just thought you've jumped the shock
here there's also the other side I guess
is he has constructed the whole
documentary he has he knows that he
knows the conclusion yeah could have you
could have recorded a lot of this later
and come back and hide it in the star
just to fill in the narrative so we it I
guess
as naive Watchers we're sort of how he's
saying this too early but maybe he has
his conclusion while missing maybe
things happened later on yeah I'm
pointing no criticisms but he's got my
interest I'll give him that
yeah I'll give him that I just think
what I'll find myself doing if it is
this much fluff in future after an hour
and a half already since the guys made
over 100 podcasts I will end up just
skipping a few minutes it's like yeah I
get the point Junior today Junior I was
watching a video earlier on YouTube and
if I'm a finger hovering over the double
tap on this side just too good I mean
it's a real 10 seconds it's just the
right amount of time skip forward yeah
it exercises the demon yeah it does yeah
I tell you what I mentioned this to you
lately
her quickly while we're on the YouTube
yeah game us on YouTube big I just I
just don't watch them there's a huge at
the moment is that something you cannot
abide love gaming group love of games is
out today is very cool yeah it's just if
you're an entertaining gamer like a
doctor disrespect with someone who's got
Lourdes a personality love that yeah
watch a bit of that no problem maybe
he's watching an episode here and there
right not still not gonna watch a load
of it but I watch that but to see like
people grow so insane like ninja for
example just not because they're
particularly like ninja seems like a
cool dude like nice nice guy I said nice
things about the commentary I love it
thanks very much me but to see how huge
a following he is built basically both
being great at a game that is
mind-blowing them and yeah that's like
wow in a way that you can't understand
it a little bit a little bit why but
also a little bit like I'm just clearly
not entertained by the same other things
because I would probably watch him don't
get me wrong I I'd watch an episode me
like if I want to get good at the game
or I just bought this game and I was
really into it I'd watch him for an
episode but to get the number of views
he's got I mean people are watching all
the [__] time
and I say Malone to me you know he's
playing the same game regularly you're
saying the same things regularly you
know he like once again he's not the
most he's not doctor disrespect I per
say he seems like a chilled out dude who
you know you can have a good
conversation with but he's not doing
that in the in the game players so I
don't know what people are getting out
of that
can i play devil's advocate yeah you
know when we were talking like Kanye you
did the whole Kanye West documentary we
make you are making another one now but
the point of that I'm helping out yeah
so much of life one and a half hours BAM
done you're welcome
yeah welcome didn't ask if he was a
sociopath once no right we asked it four
times fair play every documentary in the
future we're making a documentary on the
Queen who died was the Queen a sociopath
we find out this evening
lots of sociopaths now know the
sociopaths Network may we started that
would be a Larry just as channel all
about like oh this person a sociopath I
would love to walk into so we have a lot
of meetings with you know the agencies
influencer agencies in London guys who
you know get to the big companies doing
suckers on them some of them launch
maybe I'm joking all of them I would
love to walk them on and make a
presentation on and to these guys and
say and that's why we started the
company sociopath sink with the latest
influencer company of pure sociopaths
guys guys who will extort money out of
any young kids sociopaths on TV yeah
from fans of them who are also
sociopaths yeah what the [__] was he
doing out there I would have broken out
lying and manipulation 20 minutes
earlier tonight I mean I would have made
sure that these people knew they had to
buy the merch that I was talking oh good
that's what I like we need to bring out
a sociopath t-shirt that's for sure
morning get the most sociopathic merch
in the game yeah yes your pot shop calm
go to sociopath now online good put in
the cord socio and you but the funny
thing is it actually makes you add 20%
to the end and then when you see it you
come to us and we go we told you there
was a risk but we're just sociopaths you
can't hold us to the six line that does
your normal influential that's the funny
thing is if you put in the code socio it
may take 50 percent off it may add 30
percent I mean you trusted me that's
where you [__] up your mistake yeah
and that's what it says on the receipt
don't you just be you [__] up
sorry gamers should imagine shade doors
as well to this we're giving him too
many ideas this ninja and gamers that's
what we want anyway ninja gamers we were
talking long about Kanye West and we
were talking about how you can hear
Kanye West's personality in his beats
you can hear the soul you can hear the
sampling you can hear the way that he
does the instrumentation they're all
things that over the years when you hear
it you go this is a Kanye West beat
instantly the same with dr. Dre the same
with any producer out there you know
there are legend J Dilla people like
that legendary producers and when you
hear their beats you go that's J Dilla
instantly I'm just wondering and the
same goes for maybe I feel like with
some of my editing people watching they
go I can sort of tell Lawrence's edited
this or I can those the same goes maybe
now for gamers who are out there and
they're gaming style becomes a
personality of sorts there are seven
eight nine year olds who watch you
aren't as skilled aren't as dexterous as
a 21 year old guy and are watching you
and are thinking wow I really want a
game like this guy watching it studying
it and trying to work out how they can
become like that as well and it shows
elements of their personality that they
can game and we can see that it was that
guy playing Fortnight girl it's ninja
just through the way he's been playful
with the ways you might kill someone
he's not just trying to get a headshot
he's trying to jump 50 feet in the air
jump bounce off something else you know
jump on a friend's rocket or whatever
you want to do and get to the top of
mountain then kill the final guy in the
game that's all that skill and he's
using it in a way that matches his
personality yeah yeah I see what you're
saying because not only that I guess
with the before tonight and how it's
taken off as well like that really
helped catapult him and I kind of try
and quit that
back in the day when I was in my more
psyche when I was gaming from the moment
I woke up to the moment I went to bed
yeah and all I'd stop for was a [__]
sandwich yeah if back in those days
sandwich sorry just
turkey huntin turkey is a great sandwich
isn't it with a bit of coleslaw it's
very actress yeah Russians yeah it's
very rare you'll see a turkey sandwich
nowadays it's not enough turkey
sandwiches year round so many Christmas
we've got past so like back in the day
my game was like Metal Gear Solid grand
theft auto or those two and I guess if
that had been available to watch like
the greats play that game he Mel who
wore like way out of my league I would
have then watched that so that that
doesn't make sense I guess what I'm
trying to say is maybe a outgrown that a
little bit oh I haven't got the time or
it's it's partly time it's partly that
when you get to a certain point in your
life you start to see time slightly
differently how you spend your time also
let's face it you've got three maybe the
businesses to run at the moment you've
got EXO you've got true Geordi and the
podcast is almost its own separate thing
I can guess those sort of and the
kickoff is actually its own animal now
like that's become such a big show that
you spend so much of your week on that
yeah so your downtime is actually more
not more valuable I don't sound
pretentious like an entrepreneur setting
up all of the [__] yeah but also you now
maybe don't have that same mind time to
be able to go I'm gonna go and watch
someone game for an hour and thirty
minutes and I think that I guess one of
the things that's kind of put me off
it'd be honest is I did watch a little
bit of one of those tournaments yeah
we're like competitive gamers take on
each other and I was like a lot of
[__] money or for grabs yeah i
millions I could kind of see why that
would be exciting to people you know I
mean you're playing your favorite game
and you grind on that you're like me and
show that you're amazing
the problem is some of these games have
computing errors in the programming
where you can exploit that in the guy to
exploit that the first it's not a level
level playing field especially sports
games I think know if you play enough
then you'll find those things so it's
almost it's rewards it rewards a certain
kind of brain which can go a bit back
with poker online awesome Utley you can
see a system it spoils the fun a lot of
it when it's don't new computing errors
are not like I don't know like a
shooting game some yeah where they are
kind of more level playing field I feel
but anyway some of these guys get
interviewed after
and I'm like wow like you are you I
don't know like some of them I just feel
like I'm so different to them I would
never be able to connect with like when
I watched the UFC or like I guess
sometimes it feels like I'm disconnected
with footballers as well a lot of the
time but like if you're watching
fighting interviews they're such down if
guys who give so much a lot of the time
they're not all like Conor McGregor I
mean like they a lot of them just they
pour their emotions out after they've
had a fight and even Conor McGregor does
that a lot the time and I can connect
more with that whereas some of these
gamers I just feel like like no offense
but they a bit nerdy do you know what I
mean and that's kind of nice but so but
you can be nerdy in and emotional and
and do you think that's where ninja is
like the I think NIM just nails got that
yeah he's a good talker and when I've
seen him on interviews I'm like okay I
get why people would warm to him but
with other guys but with other guys I'm
saying make a lot of them do come across
a stereotypical like gaming like closed
in their bedroom and never ever ever
come over to its do you also because I
get that a little bit when I edit or
when I lock myself away for a while and
I have to do an edit
I don't become different but you slide
your the way your mind works changes a
little bit because you're thinking about
moving around things you're thinking
about how am I gonna make that music
work there and talking doesn't become a
challenge but it know when people talk
to me while I'm at it and I'm the rudest
[__] yeah in the world I'm like [__] off
yeah leave me a lot just get out yeah
you know I mean so dick don't know don't
say that no he would necessarily go I've
got five it would be suck it hard not
know at that point though you would want
people to understand that you've gone
into a certain mindset I guess that's
what happens to these guys isn't it I
must admit you see the frustration in
these [__] but like yeah I guess
that's what it is then and there's not
me I just haven't given it enough of the
chance it doesn't mean you have to like
it
just know did you understand that those
guys are going into that zones I mean
you watch it and go yeah cool I want to
watch that I like what with share not
anyone like we've criticized sharing a
bit but
I do admire what he's doing but from an
from a business standpoint more than
anything else you've you've you've
masterminded this scenario where
everyone's hype for your content well
done
it's a well-laid plan and a bit like I
understand I understand everything that
he's doing right now I get it
and even if I criticize it I like to in
my arena that's YouTube I like
understand why things are and I guess
with the gaming side of things like when
when ksi JJ played [__] FIFA didn't
take a [__] genius to it or why
everyone was watching he was hilarious
as well as being good at the game so
when I watch some of these guys who are
huge numbers I'm expecting the same
thing and that's when I'm left like I
think I mean yours I just wanted to
understand it a bit better for me it
also feels like there's all new genre of
gaming that these are serious hard these
guys call them selves athletes you know
what I mean they are not entertainers
who they record they are yeah they call
themselves sports athletes and just I
mean you know I mean athletes us women
I think ninja was included in the list
of he's just been on the on the front
cover of ESPN man yeah do you think
which is cool I kind of rate that as a
as an Internet blog myself like yeah
fair play mate you're breaking out you
and me and stream now good for you but
equally it's [__] because you know
there are so many athletes who probably
deserve to be on that magazine cover who
might never make it on I do worry a
little bit about that and they should
have had him with his top off with a
controller in his hand partly there was
some oh it's a podcast I was listening
to yes though they were talking about
how the MVP is voted for how you know
the best awards for FIFA mod rich won it
this year instead of Ronaldo or Messi
they were talking about how people get
bored of the same stories over and over
and over again otherwise genuinely we're
in UFC if you voted for an MVP who would
probably win it it would probably be if
it was a public vote someone like Conor
McGregor all right over and over and
over and over and it'll get boring
wouldn't it people get bored of it
people get bored of LeBron James LeBron
James is consistently the best player in
the NBA every year because he's six foot
ten or six or eight or whatever his
wingspan is [__] huge and he's a
massive
how Fargo dedicates his life to
basketball I respect that a lot but he
doesn't win MVP every year because the
MBA understands and some extent the
Premier League and FIFA are beginning to
understand if the same people are always
at the top it gets boring so if we here
are those people it gets boring the same
will happen but gaming is just so young
we can't always just chase the numbers
and people won't keep clicking in a
while on ninja they'll want to click on
it but kind of mod know that coz how
could we grow up you'll never get
anywhere playing games and you're
literally the whole the whole thing
about YouTube even a guy on the train
yesterday was like what do you do I'm a
YouTube I was just sitting there minding
my own business
yeah and was like and you make money off
that notice was like yep what I really
enjoy is the I went to a wedding
recently and people are fascinated when
I say what they go where'd you where can
I see any of your videos and I'm like
yeah on YouTube and they go no no like
somewhere serious and I'm like make that
gets more views than any other shows you
watch like name a TV show and I
guarantee you more people watching this
the guys how do you make money from that
and I'm like well it's not just one
revenue stream and they're like yeah if
it's the ads right you know like most
partly the ads yeah well I don't make
any money if they had but they can't
wrap their heads around the fact that
this is a serious industry do you know
what I mean yeah as you can't [__]
bus that's what part of me thinks I
don't want to explain it to you because
actually I don't want you to know it's
all a little thing that yeah sort of
Gogh yeah you got what she's done does
your little pricks no one ever went No
yeah but genuinely no one who made coke
in the first place went let me tell you
the recipe like the colonel keeps it
under wraps for a reason do you know
what I mean it's similar with YouTube
it's similar with all these industries
you don't want everyone to know it
speaking of food Oh while we're on it
lost six pounds on me diet this week yes
genuinely that's great
what do you do differently I just
resided in do your fat busting all week
basis so I like the food I was eating
I'd have like poached eggs on toast mmm
then got the Jim Brown bread
I think so fifty-fifty because I brought
it's a little bit it breaks up a little
bit you get that Hovis best of both am i
right yeah yeah the gym and after the
gym I have like the chuckle potato with
tuna which is nice
Naomi I'll have no mayor little little
but they make it at that they put a
little bit too much Mayo for my life but
you know what
not a lot not like me to criticize yeah
yeah although as you know you know and
then probably like a protein bar
approach it maybe both when I get back
all right a lot of people here protein
bar protein shake you and Joe of both
been critical Joella mmm-hmm friend of
friend of the show friend of the show
one of the family he was critical of
some protein stuff did it take you a
while to find because I know a lot of
people watch you fill out your tips and
stuff did it take you a while to find
the protein bar that suits you because
he just said a lot of them are just
basically a Snickers with a bit of
protein put in mmm yeah I think
sometimes you've got to be a bit picky
but I've found the right formula better
off sometimes just eating steak and
eating a protein bar food is always
better then the protein rail food is
always better protein is a supplement to
the diet so it's supposed to be
something that if you're on the go you
don't have time to make real food that's
when you'll dig into that but real food
is always the best thing you can have so
tuna steak that sort of thing always
good
yeah always turkey I like oh yeah I like
he's really good yeah it's good lean
meat it basically tastes like chicken
mistake I'm think about putting not a
vegan on my Twitter account cuz I've
seen a lot of people have veganism as a
almost like a hobby annoys me that it's
slightly so you sound like a sociopath
yeah do that yeah there's something
about what you eat on a day to day basis
a bit like putting Prius owner locally
New York you know what I mean in your in
your Twitter bio yeah thanks for doing
me a favor and saving the world by the
way German you know all the production
that went into that car was as much as
the energy they say exactly yeah [__]
went to charge it yeah why do you think
that electricity comes from burning coal
that's good
I'm an acquire wealth is new in your
life for Brian let me sister yeah we
spoken about this but I'm gonna yeah no
I'm gonna say that I'm gonna ask you
questions about it so that okay well we
haven't really gone into it any room no
I don't really have no clue oceans yo
basically obviously people know me dad
was a wild man back in the day you had
another child with another woman I met
my sister when she was born I was about
8 years old oh I ever how when she was
born as in like you were there I was I
was around in in my dad's life at that
time period but as I've said I stopped
seeing my dad a little while after that
and then she her mom moved away and I
never seen her again at that point so
because my dad stopped seeing her as
well so yeah recently we found each
other
met up it was amazing yeah yeah really
really amazing what was it like - how
did it tell me everyone like everyone's
first things are going to comment is
imagine Brian with long hair and boobs
she does not look like that no she
doesn't have a beard
no she looks like a model like no I'm
not even just saying that she looks she
could be a model of skill there's it's
mad that she's related to me yeah but um
same eyebrows yeah so we had been
chatting on messages and then we agreed
to meet up so I'm standing there at the
train station wearing the red rose I
think that out comes this tall loud
confident funny girl long hair not
running towards us and we hooked and it
was like life-changing mmm iconic I kind
of describe it any other way like I
could feel like electricity going
through me buddy like I was like oh this
is real like this is love this is actual
like absolute love general I mean like
I've never um I felt that before
obviously but like it had been a while
from like to have that family just
moment you know I mean I'm like a home
it's unreal unreal it was like no enemy
whole life you straight away it was a
mad and I've kind of always been
skeptical about I've mentioned in the
past about family blood to take other
more up or you know but you get let down
by family and in yada yada yada and
mystic I just felt so different it was
[__] mind blown and you connected
straightaway yeah yeah I told her I
loved her and certainly I felt that it
was like [__] hell like but I it was
on a different level to logic it was
like I I feel like you're part of me
like an intuition I can just feel it
yeah and then yeah we spent the day
together what did you do yeah I just
said let's get drunk and tell each other
our life stories basic right and just
catch up and like everything that's
happened just sort of giver and like we
just ended up like laughing obviously
there's a few tears because we had sad
stuff happen and we were both like sort
of I don't know because we connected so
quickly we opened up really quickly yeah
so it was great but we had such a laugh
um you had lots in common state of mind
like little little things where you're
like [__] genetics are a real thing
like because she thinks like me on
certain things she likes a scroller yeah
probably yeah no just bad she had great
by now like we had a right good life and
such she's such a personality like
that's where I found the connection like
not an inward person or whatever she's
just loud and proud and just a herself
like not frightened to just speak our
mind and I love that yeah yeah you're my
sister Hitler and that's yeah there's
something about and you've not had that
so you sort of you I guess there's the
worry beforehand what if we don't get on
what if oh you're so different I wasn't
expecting it to be like that though like
I'd be like life change right away yeah
it cuz it it had an impact on me like
that I didn't expect the two so like
when we had a really good life um
to the train station next day when I was
saying bye to I got really upset like I
was like [__] hell I've only just got
you back and now you're gone yeah and
she left he was like don't worry I'll
not take 21 years yeah but it made me
think about women in a totally different
way as well yeah like what I want in
life mid made me
it had a like an epiphany of like that
feeling and that connection I want that
for the rest of my life you know I'm
saying just about moving forward and
just did it so change exists when you
that is something that's really key
about having women in your life if
you're a man and men in your life if
you're and then building relationships
for those people they change how you
think about other women in your life and
the way that everything set up
mmm big-time is anything big toe is a as
a man you always want to have close
relationships not necessarily with lots
of women but with you you know your mom
or if you have a sister or a cousin or
something like that it was it was both
things really shaped the way that you
have relations and if it fell
unconditional as well it felt like we've
got each other's back like we both came
into this with a great attitude and she
is a really special person like she's I
see a lot enough children I mean and I
gasai she's funny she's charismatic
she's like herself to it like there's no
holding back and she is just like I love
her to bits you know I mean I could I
could just feel it coming out of me
[__] chest almost it was yeah it just
made us realize like all right this is
what it's supposed to feel like you know
I mean which is and when you've not had
that I imagine that's quite a a big
emotion to feel you know
yeah I mean obviously I've had that with
my mother but it just reinforced it like
yeah that's that's the feeling like it's
amazing and yeah just moving forward
with me life it just made it just it
rocked me but in the best way possible
like holy [__] like I need to be much
more over this I need who I have in my
life I need be really really picky about
mmm and because that's the level really
mm-hmm
general I mean that's why I should be
feeling when I'm around people that I'm
close with Jeanne and I mean so it was
it was [__] amazing
um yeah I've got lots of plans with all
kind of say say what's next yeah it's
gonna be good I don't really take the
zoo I'd already talked I sure made it
I'd already talked about stuff like this
on the podcast but I I felt like it was
such a moment in me life like one of the
best days of my life you could see
actually I think you text me almost like
straight away since you dare you took a
picture with her and you sent it to me
and ever since you've you've been quite
different even almost like more upbeat
more sort of full of actual life I think
a lot of the time as well when you're
you YouTube can be quite draining
because we're all sociopaths it can be
quite draining so it there's times where
actually you don't feel like doing a
podcast and it's fair to say that
actually over the last few weeks have
been plenty of times where you and I
have had the conversation oh should we
just sat the podcast off today
not so feeling lazy or we don't
appreciate it it was that you in
particular we're not feeling like you
wanted to just sit down and have a chat
for the sake of having a chat and since
I think there is probably a bit of a
change in that and it you know I'm not
saying we're not tough enough to sit
down and have a chat about things but I
think it's almost just seeing a
difference you can tell when someone's
just having a chat for the sake of it
and when someone's actually got
something to say you know I mean I just
feel like
I could say a lot of gooey [__] right
now
like I could go on and on and on because
that's how I feel you know I mean but
like I feel like I was in a place where
you know if I was to liken it to color I
was in like a not a dark place but like
a gray place so I was like and then she
was like a [__] rainbow just smashing
it there wasn't be like like color hot
this right and it was there I was like
[__] now like unbelievable
just insane do um that's the most weird
[__] I've ever come up with in my life
but I can't quantify it like she's an
amazing person and she makes me feel
great when I was really it was weird cuz
I was watching her like we were about to
go out and do something over she was
getting ready and she was putting our
makeup on and I was like just one of
what you put your makeup on because I
haven't done this before yeah I mean
just a little thing little quirks about
her and stuff like that she really likes
food this fossil it's just like uncanny
like I've met the one woman in my life
who likes food as much no literally I
was like how are you so skinny like this
is [__] and I've been gypped yeah
there's almost like legends she said
don't worry we'll buy some new ones yeah
the is I know it I know it sounds funny
save it it's a bit like it and I imagine
it almost like an Adam Sandler movie
wait it was almost like you but you play
every time no she looks well you know
she looks very different than me yes was
it um not nervous beforehand but you get
like a sense of anticipation oh man when
I was started the transition I was like
nervous but really excited and when I
seen that I could have like lift out a
footman shoes I was just think Hogan are
and it was great it was like it felt so
natural
I could imagine have grown up with that
like I could imagine arguing about who
gets the [__] bathroom and [__]
like that like I was like yeah we're
we're connected me and you like there's
no I can feel it because there's a it's
not like it's not like that [__]
that people say I can actually feel like
on a deep level like
I'm a part of heard she's a part of me I
could feel it it almost I you know every
cloud Boesel thing it almost helps that
you had that time apart because then
when you do see those similarities I
think a lot of families when they spend
enough time together almost familiarity
breeds contempt the fact that you two
are not familiar with each other but
then you see each other and you
understand it almost gives you a
different kind of noise I did it was
bittersweet because on the one hand if
I've grown up with her I might have felt
a bit more I might not have appreciated
as much as what I do yeah
and but it is sad that I've missed all
those years with her but equally we've
both got plenty as ahead where we can do
something about it and make sure we've
got a real good like bond there and I'm
definitely going to do that and
hopefully I'll make a good big brother
yeah pretty much in there imagine me her
someone brick and a heart imagine that
that's part of it is that can you
imagine that we might we might
girlfriend I've met a few of her family
and they've told me if you ever hurt or
I'll break and you I know with family
you sort of just get that vibe don't you
see that because you know there's
there's science which says that even if
you go another up getting people
watching like they don't feel
particularly close to their family or
whatever no but I have never heard that
really yeah so with my mum but and but
I've not felt that connection with
another human being before where I felt
like I don't know a [__] spirits are
real and all this bullet I don't know
but like if it feels like there's
something in there that's a part of me
that's a part of yeah she's a pause
literally the case you share genes you
share like it feels like that gentleman
it feels connected yeah and so other
that was the they it's just not happened
you know I mean which because there is
science which says like there if you
look at a picture of your family you
will become happier you will actually be
a happier person just from looking at
old pictures of your family there's some
old pictures of my own family I don't
know
no but that's probably burnished yeah
but that's what I'm saying right it is
not everyone gets that feeling and not
everyone is lucky enough to have that
feel no I felt like I'd won the lottery
and I when I was single a few years ago
quite a few years ago now I've been
longer all right it's a long long time
ago now but a while since I had a one
Cattleya for a good reason
the point is when I was one of those
people have walked down the street and
I'd look at other people who were in
love and I'd be like Chris Rock does the
difference between men and women and he
goes when when a woman's best friend
comes and goes I've got a new man he is
[__] great like is this these that is
the other and women look at this guy and
they meet him the go
I want him yeah whereas men go how do
you get me a girl just like my dad
scoffs totally different attitudes so I
look around I look around I look around
on I remember being single on
Valentine's Day and looking around and
all these loved-up people and I what I'm
saying this because there'll be people
out there who a lot of people write to
us and they are never form that I was a
family they've had fallen out with their
sister their brother all these people
and they resent those people or
girlfriends or whoever right I remember
looking around on Valentine's Day me
like it's just so many lovely people in
the world and they're all falling in
love and I sort of feel the same for you
now but in a very much a closer way
where when you see someone else is so
happy because of that experience you
almost feel happier yourself because of
it do you know what I mean dog mill of
being bosom yeah no you can tell you can
tell I got a message from home like you
get excited you read it yeah yeah which
is weird because so I I do being
obviously being a grown-ass man thirty
years old not know an s main call
themselves the the days of me getting
excited or for text message Oliver I've
gone and a long time ago and obviously
like it give me a feeling like oh this
is foot like it's nice to feel like this
you know a woman that you were dating or
whatever would would text you it's
different though it's different it was
the same kind it's almost like I feel
quite childish when I get a
to offer because they do you know me
yeah yeah and this is raw truth you know
when it when it's a message off a girl
who you know you're trying to move from
a baby with it's a different kind of
excitement altogether obvious different
yeah obviously there's a different kind
of dynamic here yeah it's not the same
so maybe isn't something you're used to
no I got being like a big brother on
this it's fun I'm and I like it
do you know me and it's like I'm trying
to feel like I'm meant to be like that
kind of guy I think I might change your
love life no I've already felt that very
let's meet Martin like I say if my
attitude towards women's just changed
yeah but that doesn't mean I'm not gonna
make sexist jokes every now and then
because this is who I am
but inside inside yeah it has made me
think of it hasn't changed my opinion on
women as a whole no it's made me think
that women I do really like that I
should treat a little differently right
and that's respectable right yeah I'm
I'm trying to be a better I did I'm
gonna try to be a better man speaking of
which you we were talking earlier about
the way that women are portrayed in
society anyway oh yeah because there's
been a lot of controversy or chat around
that they had that big fat girl on there
and that's a very healthy way of
speaking about women hmm
she is a big she was a member a [__]
name but yeah big fat girl so there was
a woman who was much bigger than maybe
you say the average woman in society or
something
I'm gonna have to bring it out because
otherwise it feels disrespectful to
speak about someone and call them the
big fat girl cause more fat cover
alright s holiday I want to know have
phone I want to know
[Music]
holiday how much she weighs if I can
wait
she was 280 pound rough and she's five
foot five so I just put this in
perspective I'm about six four and after
my little weight loss yeah that's weak
because some of us do restrict ourselves
on the let's just all get Brian hmm
I'm not far off the same way as her
there's about twenty pounds in it I have
you know me I think I paid a lot of
attention to this cover can I see the
cover so Tess hollow do you bring it up
yeah good good guide you so that's right
that's how she's just a a very very
large woman right now obviously she's
quite a pretty girl like you know they
they're trying to I'm not sure what the
goal was with with with Kosmos from
putting her on the front but Joe Rogan
came at it from a very direct angle for
giorgos he sits on the fence a bit he
tries to play the voice of common sense
abstract yeah he but he was like you
know you're a lot of people are coming
out now because of this and saying
things along the lines of you know this
is a you can be fat and healthy and
Joe's just called [__] on that you
know Point Blank yes true you can be you
can be on the large side and be healthy
you can be precise and healthy but when
you're morbidly obese you are not
healthy you're not [__] healthy and
when people say well I'm look at me I'm
still here and he's like yeah well you
can smoke cigarettes and still be here
as well but eventually you're gonna pay
the price for that what you put your
body through and it's no different in
what jaws pipe was is that he was a bit
pissed off I don't want to call him
exactly but he kind of said it
Nicholas that if we had a 300-pound
five-foot-five fat man in his underwear
on a [__] magazine cover we'd look at
him say there's a fat slob right
he needs to sort it out do something
about it but when it's a woman
well I oh you're beautiful you're so
beautiful like you're fat but you're bit
like right and it's ridiculous you know
women just as much as men should be
subjected to the reality of the
situation which is that you're morbidly
obese and you're shortening your
lifespan muscley I know some people
might be watching us for the first time
and said that fat guys full of [__]
[__] about me I'm aware of that as well
I'm trying to do something yeah I'm
gonna [__] die though I'm trying to
do something about it and I'm sick I'm a
foot taller than this woman ran about
the same way yeah that's wrong with this
picture right all right well you're too
fat she can be far as she wants and for
the record I like bigger women I I
genuinely find like you know plus-sized
women attractive but not the kind of
people that need to go on Jerry Springer
not the ones who you have to cook the
side of their house off to be a little
ear
you're not saying she has to cut the
side of our house off no she doesn't
leave no she's modeling yes it boosts to
me is where the line is drawn because I
don't think that that's good for them
let's also be very clear we were talking
about throwing terms like sociopath
around you know when we're having and
I'm not saying you're thrown terms
around there are different terms for
being big right some people are big some
people are obese to be obese is
unhealthy and it's just because we have
a top end of the scale which is you know
morbidly obese clinically obese whatever
you wanna say doesn't mean a B C's is
good
do you know Abby's is still not a great
oh that's bad I'm or beast technically
right now I'm trying to do something
about right you're not I'm saying and
they're my eyes that is you can also be
sucking integer minutes one of them
enough I guess
yeah and it's about finding a scale it's
also about finding something is this is
about women and and they're how people
treat them basically is what Joe was
saying and that it's ridiculous that we
baby people I think you know from the
truth like you're you're morbidly obese
that's not a good thing that's not
something to be celebrated
if someone a it
I think what the point that jaws kind of
making is it's the same if we put
there's a reason why promoting
cigarettes has been banned because we
don't want people to be encouraged to
take something up because they say it
advertised everywhere
yeah and for the same reason we
shouldn't be promoting a morbidly obese
body image because we don't want to
normalize it you know what I'm saying so
and we're doing that because what he's
saying is I think or the general
consensus is we're doing that to make
people feel better about how they look
which I appreciate
yeah I don't want anyone to feel bad
about how they love now but medically
speaking scientifically speaking you
have to sometimes just accept the facts
of this isn't good for you yeah and I
guess to add on to that and I don't know
how deep you and I haven't seen the clip
he cut pretty quick through it yeah I
like that
ie smushed it but then to dig a little
bit deeper on that you can look healthy
and be really sick some people have you
know terminal cancer and can look
perfectly well that person does not walk
around and say everything's fine I'm
perfectly healthy do you know the same
with people who are you know smokers all
those sorts of things I guess the big a
big problem for me as well is they still
give it a makeup they still give her the
hair that a skinny model would have they
still give it a swimsuit they still
package your up in the same way as you
were packaged someone up who is the
reverse classic Victoria Secret model
they won't let a look grow and they talk
about breaking down barriers of you know
we're not here to be dolls for men we're
not here to be what men want us to be I
still don't believe people are still
seeing that but it you really think men
give a [__] about lift fellas and all
this other [__] that women are doing
a 95% 99% of men don't give a [__] a lot
of this is about women doing stuff to
make themselves feel better and I
support that but the deer's of people
all put I've seen people going it was
just some old actress or whatever I was
on Twitter [__] banging on about
we're not here for mentor George Norris
and [__] hell those are two separate
but I mean some people aren't there no
one's there for men to judge and no
this [__] about how men dictate the
image of women or whatever women are
firmly in control of their own image
these days or more in control if
anything them more so than men are I
think women are going off in the wrong
direction I support that they do you but
you know that we're not the ones to be
trying to impress anymore that's not
this is about no well I think it's it's
that there is not one there will be a
lot of women out there who may be
watching this and are thinking well I
dress up to impress my boyfriend or I
dress up to impress my friends but you
can dress up to impress multiple people
you don't got to up obviously you know
Beyonce's line 50 years ago society was
the way of you know what about what men
expect from women and I and things have
changed and let's not continue
bullshitting as if because I don't know
women the whole [__] independent
women vibe that like twenty years ago on
that like that's been and gone now we've
except men have accepted that men are a
dying [__] breed yeah at you know I
said what a dying breed some men the
women used to be it's [__] over let's
be honest do you mourn that or do you I
I am sad when I I hear how may not award
to women these days I think in what way
well women run run [__] now like let's
be honest and do you think I said well
that's not a problem that is it that
women run I know I think it's gone from
one extreme to the other the other yeah
mate rien patriarchy yeah I think we've
gone from men being overly in control to
generally now women are in control
because we've cheered like you know from
divorce laws and that in the way things
go on like women just have so much power
now I think that's the ban are a lot
more aggressive than they ever once were
I guess thank and does that is that
problem do you think or do you think
it's just that women are I think it
should just be in relationships 5050
like you know you have your see I have
my see but because naturally one person
will be dominant but I think we're just
seeing a lot more women who are like and
I kinda like how women are
going out now in getting careers and
they not expect it to be I mean people
could pause this right now and critique
me I do like that women who can do what
they want I think that's good
but equally things are changed and a lot
later I mean part of it for me also
feels grandparents are raising children
these days because women are having kids
kicking them to the ground I'm going
back to my career and it's like well you
know you would position to raise the kid
why did you have it it's also not the
worst thing to have a grandparent that
raises a child that can be a perfectly
healthy home sometimes but it's not the
[__] it's not the planet in general
is it no I'm going off on a tangent all
it's not what I think should be
happening one thing that is interesting
and it's a lot to unpack in the point
that Cosmopolitan cover strikes me less
as empowered women or a message to men
or and it it strikes me as consumerism
wrapping up the idea of being empowered
sort of shock a little bit look what
we're doing though look at us people
actually give a [__] about Cosmopolitan
look good partly all that maybe to me it
makes a statement quite a few statements
on many different levels but one of the
main stem uses makes is look how you can
be bigger and you can still fit in with
what other women think is the mainstream
and think is you can sell a makeup in
the same way as all the pretty the girls
that you know the pretty girls in the
traditional sense hold themselves up to
you can still look the same
even though you weigh whatever it is
that you're a you can and the point for
me is it's not about being happy the
happiness is the start of where you are
if you are overweight it's not about
being happy and then just accepting it
and then go and cool well would just be
300 pounds for the rest of our lives
then that's not healthy the happiness is
the beginning to then go and okay I'm
happy now I feel happy enough to be able
to go and workout or happy enough to be
able to you know curb may be unhealthy
eating habits or you know be able to go
and earn some money so that I don't have
to buy just cheap as my own health you
have to have a little bit of inner
happiness in order to get your [__]
together like let's take it's taken me a
little while to start wanting to do
something good feel like do cardio and
all
and when you start doing it you're like
yeah I'm getting somewhere here and then
you get more happy or whatever but the
interesting side is we've broken down a
lot of the myths that surrounded men so
about men being the only ones who are
able to be powerful and dominant and
it's instead of breaking down those
myths and then coming to a common truth
which I don't know if we can find anyway
we seem to have built up some other
myths in order just to sell other things
so instead of now selling products to
men we sell more products to women we
have expensive makeup we have expensive
hair dye we're all these whatever you
want to call it all those things that
cover is to sell to a wider mass market
that may originally had because that is
gonna make them more money in the long
term and we're still selling the same
image whether the woman is big I don't
know where that's the correct is more
yeah we're so we've done our up exactly
that they were all going to go to Mac in
the end well they're all gonna go to a
shop America I've been to buy bitter
Christmas and birthday presents on
wheels they're all gonna go to Mac in
the end they're all gonna go to Bob
Bobby Brown or ever you want to call it
and they're all gonna go and live eyes
good presence great presence Mac is a
great shop to go to and they give you
great help so you're all gonna go in the
same place in the end you're gonna buy
the same product and maybe before some
of those girls are some of the women
didn't think in that same way there's
also the other side to it which I'd be
interested to get your opinion on is are
in the same way with a Shane Dawson
documentary if we're conscious actors
and we're not just there taking any
information and taking it on face value
then what does the cover really do for
us does it start a conversation between
men and women about what is healthy is
it to shock people into saying something
like Joe Rogan says which is that's not
healthy I don't agree with that is that
good that we can have one side of the
argument to spark Joe Rogan site because
Joe Rogan is one of the few
[__] out there was a big voice
you'll say something about it though
that's the thing I like about Joey's a
[__] man but is that good that
cosmopolitan can say that and Joe
Rogan's got his platform say that it
doesn't just if we only came to the
conclusion which is you know women are
beautiful no matter what or whatever
women or everyone's beautiful but we
need to find a way to lose weight
people would go yeah but how did you get
to that conclusion and you would not
have that [__] man everyone's
beautiful absolute bollocks order we're
not pretty
everyone's well we're all into something
different we're all into one thing and
yeah everyone is don't wrong everyone is
there
I don't it's I think we should just
treat everyone fairly you know right
we're all one thing we're all unique
we're not fair do you think society is
right just when people say everyone's
beautiful like I get where they're
coming from and they're not meaning it
in a bad way but I just think it's
wishy-washy crud so how fair do you
think society is right now
what's completely unfair yes totally
it's the whole thing so wrong do you not
I mean
do you his question do you think we can
ever get to a point where society is
fair no someone will always suffer so
what do we do just keep working on it
try and keep making things better where
are we going with this this is I'm just
I guess there are a lot of people who'd
be interested to know whether you like
whether broad for me personally say I'm
realistic goals in society to try and
get something that we can never get to
and we're just distracting ourselves
maybe that's what podcasts are for
Lawrence pop what to distract setting
unrealistic goals yeah sorry if we
brought the mood down it's not a mood
we've been high we've been low within
wherever you want to go do we do we've
got any problem oh we've got loads of
pile of soot some problems I love bad
problems that's my [__] problem
hi my name is Lydia and I have split
parents and have had for years but I
wanted to talk about my dad's recent
wife just wanted to know if this is
serious or just like a jokey thing that
goes up on YouTube basically this girl's
wandering with her dad's new wife should
she be worried about you know getting
left out of things how when when your
parents move on after they get divorced
how do you deal with her
hmm I was very young when it happened
but uh I don't know is it if his if he's
traded his old wife in for a younger
much hotter model will traded he might
be you know a little bit excited to
start off with you know enjoying life
again men get very like they're like
little dogs mint you know I mean we
really are a little dogs you know when
we get a new toy you know me and me
alone
we can't wait to play with it but
eventually wow he will he will calm down
and he will come back to his favorite
toy which is his daughter I guess this
has got weird when you're when your
parents break up that there is often a
worry inside you is a child of divorce
that you will be left behind that
there'll be so much happiness in their
new life that you'll remind them of the
old life and it'll be like oh why did
you know why did we have you do you know
what I mean been a bit depressed to a
lot of kids feel that way they don't
know I I know I know what you mean but
you know your dad if he doesn't make you
feel the way he should and you start
feeling a bit left out just tell him
just tell him and you know more starts
will a good dad will respond to that
well and be like okay I need to make
more of an effort
I'm getting a bit wrapped up in my new
situation just communication
communication is always key
this is admit and also showing love be
loving towards someone react what up the
gang signs yeah literally just walk into
your dad and be like y'all was good
I've got another question here so my
story starts with this girl who sits
next to me at school I've liked her for
a while but then I'm in trying to push
questions in about who she likes and she
says she doesn't like anyone in our
school I'm in year 11 we've been good
friends for a while so do I bite the
bullet and tell her how I feel or do I
not tell her and forget this ever
happened love the podcast by the way
this get Sean back for a part for
believe me Sean Atwood has come back for
a couple I saw Wildman the other day on
his youtube channel showing people how
to cook prison food unbelievable Oh
as for telling a girl how you feel I
hate to move on but it's it's such a
[__] question really for me why is
it's like feel so real to this species
or not but you've got a you've got to do
that in life you're not I mean you've
got it a lay yourself out there a bit
and just be vulnerable if you get hurt
it'll only help you in the future
because you're gonna just grow from that
that's fine don't worry boy stop
worrying about your reputation so much
stop caring about what everyone thinks
just say the girl do privately just say
look can I talk to you about never
publicly right just say can I talk about
something I'm a little bit you know
embarrassed but I just wanted to talk to
you and I would appreciate if you just
kept this between us because I do feel a
little bit silly but I like you I was
wondering if you like me and you know if
so know me okay maybe we could hang out
more if not then say friends it's cool
I'll just cut you off you you you have
to make it out like it's not as big of a
deal as what cuz in school a little bit
like YouTube every little thing gets
blown out of proportion everyone's a
sociopath that's the key word for it
isn't it but if so see if you present it
to her in a really relaxed and chilled
out way if she then shoots you down it's
not gonna feel as bad and she's not
gonna feel as awkward around you so it's
like it never happened
do you know I mean although to her it
will always have happened she'll note it
and then never get as close with you
again so just be absolutely clear that
you want so you just ruined yes no no
when a guy comes out to a guy remember
this happened in our high school there's
so many guys and girls guys would go and
they you know they're shoot their shot
and then a shot didn't land you know
they didn't hit three do you know what I
mean I asked the girl at once and she
just sort of shook her yeah wow that's
harsh well no but she was clearly
embarrassed by the situation and I just
really can't agree with friends no she
was like on her own but she was like
when I was like okay then that'll be
amazing cuz you walked over and when she
got some time
ironically
the girl kind of was impressed by like
status a lot Wow
own like she just look at you know she
got with the after school she got with
one of the guys who got a job first and
had a bit money first that was sort of
her her layin and now like this is what
you could have had [__] let me yeah
you're a bit like the speedboat on
bullseye I am yeah people don't know
that that's a game sure where they used
to give a real good prize a win in this
analogy arm the speedboat on the prize
someone who lives in the [__]
Midlands yeah you live in Lincoln and
you've just won a speedboat just gonna
tell my friends about it and then never
write it yeah hey loss Ryan and blah
blah blah
my name is and I live in mmm one of my
colleagues at work let's call him mm-hmm
is a bit weird he often talks about sex
and we have some dodgy stuff on his Mac
computer well one day I invited him
around for dinner like you do with any
sex obsess colleague and he acted weird
around my daughter who was just sixteen
I don't I don't I don't know if I
believe this to be honest with you it's
the the the way they've set this up
zones sounds bullsh what he's basically
asking is how do I treat this guy who
seems sex-obsessed right a guy seems
sex-obsessed and he's acting weird
around your child probably back the [__]
away that's never clever
moving on smart yeah yeah back the [__]
away don't talk to him no more yeah do
you know one picture where he realized
his new me it was actually a Nazi she
don't know me right yeah yeah in that
you've just realized your friend is
actually a sociopath oh [__] yeah
goodbye
back away although any sudden movements
they're unpredictable a Shane Dawson
sociopath documentary featuring a little
bit of Jake Paul's channel it is funny
though it's funny though when you you
basically you fix Jake Paul in one place
and then you just attach all these
different qualities to him you basically
go sociopath I thinking I start thinking
if we had a video made about you for
example yeah and we had highlights of
you where you say a sort of nasty little
comment
on the podcast crazy [__] a little bit
of dark music then a clip of a woman
putting a cut in a bin yeah and then a
plane crash yeah a bank robbery and just
be like and Laurence McKenna is a prime
example of why you shouldn't do these
things cite the psycho killing in the
shower I feel like you could make any
the editing is so good you can make
anyone just look crazy
ya know you genuinely can yeah that's
the obvious it's made easier by the fact
that Joe Paul has done some dodgy [__]
it's the classic it's Simon but another
no but people love this sort of [__] so
Alfred Hitchcock oh no no no no no we're
not doing Alfred ships what we're doing
yeah but just to finish that point
Alfred Hitchcock said he spoke about the
shot getting the smile from a man right
and you know where he goes and that was
not the Joker who said that no let's put
a smile on my face where are they so
usually offer them soon excited and I
was quite excited about a working
Phoenix good choice
great choice if anyone can do it it's
got to be him he's got the hair that
Heath Ledger has horrible mud the same
latitude Heath Ledger had the same sort
of sensibility was amazing the Gaggia
yeah anyway so will any will have
switched off no because he doesn't like
movies you Eddie
it's over you edit a picture of a woman
with a baby at the start man smiling in
the middle the another woman a picture
with a baby you you think that man is
kind he he thinks about women and he
thinks about them being caring and nice
people you edit a picture of a woman in
a bikini same picture of a man smiling
back to the woman in the bikini you
think that man is a horrible guy that's
what I've done before shoot that yet but
that is what this partly this
documentary feels like to me if you edit
a plane crash in around Jake Paul Keim
let's go
it makes it seem like he did oh my gosh
yeah yeah joke Paul is a terrorist and
we finally got the problem and we
finally know who did 9/11
insta friend-zoned this will be a good
one hi my name is man I go to school I'm
rate about eight out of ten with girls
okay he's another one of those
sociopaths
who can you tell me how much people rate
you what number do you think people give
you what I think they would give me what
number did it varies so much but I would
have that law I would have thought at a
guess Safin out return seven being
honest though okay
but the thing is it varies because I'm
such a niche market your wall so I think
there are some women who'd look at me
and think fault yeah but there are some
who think named June and I mean yeah
that's why I've gone for seven yeah and
then they meet you and it's a seven I'm
from Ireland I like this girl and I'm
not sure if she likes me or not just
seems just seems like it though girls
are hot because she's always texting me
she she's always I think he meant some
input her but he put puta which means
something bad she always put her head on
my shoulder she likes you and she's
sucker and so c'mon look anyway I'm a
bit fat though and she's proper
good-looking can you give me some advice
on what to do it's tricky because you
know Politan cuz I'm not a Dutch is
gonna make you stay [__] Chinon I mean I
don't know if that's how it works
I don't think that is the way it works
if he wants to get in sheriff call you
know do a bit called you're gonna die
it's not feeling good about yourself but
he's asked but he's not asking about
that he's asking does she like me now
some girls like cuddly [__] men
genuinely there's girls out there when
I've talked about losing weight they're
like oh no oh no I'm like why they're
like oh I like you thick with 2 C's boy
and I'm wow I'm always gonna be thick
don't worry about that someone built I
like you thick with two CS what the gold
the call made the girls here Wow yeah
the girls cook the sorry the girls call
you thick with two c's yeah that's what
they say right
was that not there's another thing I
mean it's definitely that's what I've
been saying like yeah went so what when
you take all your clothes off they go
and no no I was like on the Instagram
shittin though in the comment and like
thick with two seas or
daddy as [__] as well as a comment I've
had lately
which is a little bit on the Sun that's
on the side just went up Carl Icahn
spiney grossed out by that but yeah
would you say that sociopathic I would I
wouldn't I just say that's a rata sysm
that's what they're feeling they're
feeling it through their in their
vaginas on this sick they're feeling the
that they're funny fluttering isn't it
but the thought of me makes me feel ill
yeah look at all the change we can see
after and they owe on the dress on the
bedside dresser someone here is saying
he's too nice I'm 17 are you cautioning
me nice at 17 I think I'm too nice girls
always seem to go for bell ends and use
nice guys and ask nice guys never seem
to get a look-in I'd say I'm a decent
looking lad and have a pretty good chat
hmm
I've always been I've always I've been
seeing a couple of girls at the same
time because he's a nice guy but never
anything really serious what advice
would you give to the nice guys tell
them to [__] off
tell girls to [__] off right as soon as
you treat a girl a little bit [__]
like you're not asked it's amazing it is
I remember being with girls where I made
the effort you know and they have maybe
not being as keen right in a minute I'm
like look you're not making an FFL
you're done [__] off and I'm like
dismissed them that is when the effort
levels go up 10 all of a sudden they're
like he told me to [__] off like out of
nowhere the complacency with them then
gone you know and then they just seemed
more interested out of nowhere there's a
point where I saw thinking I might just
go down the street and start telling
every girl [__] off right you [__] you
[__] off you [__] off and just see if
one of them turns out goes I want to
[__] him right because it's amazing low
like to say that almost zero when I
decide I'm not interested in a woman
it's amazing how much they all of a
sudden become more interested right what
so you get what I'm saying up women I
can't the kind of one what they can't
hurt women want a challenge women
a fixer up mother they don't want a guy
who is going to be easy to walk all over
and get what they want from because
where's the fun in that they want to
feel like there's a bit of a bit of an
issue a bit of a challenge or something
do write compete with something to have
an issue so you're saying treating me
and keep them keen not not 100% right
because you've got a you're walking out
walking out it's going to be you but
equally if a girl is just bored with you
you have to show her that there's more
to you than just mr. nice guys
by keeping exciting women women women
like a man with a bit of an edge to them
and even if it's not as much of a
[__] edge as what I've got because
like there's a bit too much [__] so
much in me clearly
women like women like a man who is not
frayed all of them in their [__]
place when need be because we all need
to be checked but some men are such
[__] wet wipes out there that when a
woman goes full [__] they'll just be
like sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry when it's
not even your fault maybe back you just
love her so much and you just love her
so much that you're willing to be a
[__] wet wife for her and I'll walk
all over you you were doing yourself a
favor by checking her and saying I'll
not let you treat me like [__] and
you're doing her a favor because she'll
want to [__] you more if she looks at
you and respects you right I'm here all
week [__] try the veal I think
I've done enough there me yeah I think
I've said enough my other side to that
is you can also build respect with women
just by doing nice things as well
lots of teamwork oh yeah treat them mean
keep them keen no treat them bad
sometimes you'll make them mad it goes
both ways
let's wrap it up those are some great
problems it's been a fun show don't
forget there are loads of business
problems we need to go through and now
we do have a meeting later on today but
for now thanks to everyone who's keying
by luckily I don't have 17 million
subscribers so this is more of a
community it's a community
I was so glad we do enough 717 million
yeah cuz there for all that money have
been rubbish
not as much connection yeah Jeremy you
know I'm a man of integrity I don't want
to sacrifice that I'm happy to keep a
small circle of sociopaths rather than
17 million nor most I just want 10
million yeah I mean just a small circle
yeah and then yeah all good ones there's
six billion people in the world do you
know I don't mean too many yeah many who
needs all about get rid of some
so yeah that's what sociopaths would say
there's a sociopath to Midland and me
ain't a crime otherwise known as the
police don't arrest me just yeah hit the
like button and subscribe for more
thanks for watching see ya